[Music]
I'd like to welcome you to our afternoon
panel entitled oil spill issues i'm hank
marcus from the ocean engineering
department and we're celebrating our
hundredth anniversary of having ocean
engineering at MIT and so we're
delighted to have you here and we're
delighted to have maritime panels this
afternoon
since the grounding and the Exxon Valdez
in March 1989 the the maritime industry
has been a very exciting industry lots
of lots of things going on here now I'm
sure you've all heard of the Oil
Pollution Act of 1990 that's been one of
the one of the major events over the
past four years let me just bring up two
more points that you may not be as
familiar with if you start comparing
some of the oil pollution data from the
early 70s to the early 90s you see some
interesting things I chaired a marine
board panel and we dug out the data and
you see that if you start with the years
73 75 at one end and 1990 at the other
end you see that over this time span the
amount of oil that has gone into the
ocean as a result of tanker accidents
has decreased by 45% and the amount of
oil that's gone into the ocean from
tankers as part of their operational
discharges such as pumping out ballast
water has decreased by 85 percent now we
still feel that there's more to be done
and and the what's we're doing today is
still not acceptable but we've had quite
an improvement over the past two decades
the second point I want to make is that
we face a rather unique situation with
the US Congress relative to the design
of tankers in this country and that's
has to do with with the way they passed
the Oil Pollution Act of 1990 basically
we could we could say we have Congress
designing our tankers and and given the
naval architecture experience and
expertise of Congress that that scares
me now it's it's certainly an
overstatement to put it that way
but when Congress passed the Oil
Pollution Act of 1990 they didn't say
well gee why don't we identify all the
causes of environmental damage from oil
pollution and then we'll analyze each
one and see what the best cost ratio is
so we know where to put our money to get
the the maximum ratio between benefits
and costs that would have been one
approach they they didn't do that and
they didn't say well why don't we come
up with how do we develop some
performance standards here like we do
with cars what we say is you know under
these kinds of circumstances you drive
the car into the wall or whatever we
want the car to perform in a certain way
you know we could do that with ships and
then you that way you leave it up to the
designers and the naval architects and
engineers to come up with the best way
of meeting those needs they didn't do
that either
basically they sort of said read my
ships no new tankers without double
hulls and that's sort of a inaudible
Coast Guard and they did that in the act
but if you look at Congress's role in
the design the structural design of any
other vehicle of any other
transportation mode in the United States
Congress has never taken such a strong
stand whether we're talking about cars
or trucks or buses or planes or trains
this is a rather unique role now you
might ask why is that what is the
Congress or how does the Congress or the
general public perceive the whole
maritime industry or the universities
that train people in these industries or
the types of research programs we have
now indeed you might ask that but you
can't ask that till after you hear from
four experts we have here and and this
afternoon first we're going to hear from
our regulator Admiral chyme from the
Coast Guard who has the responsibility
of implementing many of the provisions
the OPA is as well as a few other things
the Coast Guard does in their spare time
myriad number next we're going to hear
from from upon on December eCos
representing independent tanker owners
who have to deal with all the
regulations in the world then we're
going to hear from Richard quakin
representing the the oil companies who
must deal with the regulations and and
the independent tanker owners in their
own fleets and company owned vessels
finally we're going to hear from Lisa
Martinez represent it says representing
environmentalists is what it says in
your booklet now I happen to think that
all of us up here environmentalists but
indeed Lisa has spent a lot of time
working on environmental research and
integrating the disciplines of
engineering with environmental science
and she's going to put some of this
discussion in a broader perspective of
oil pollution in general the format
we're going to follow is as follows each
speaker will have about 15 minutes to
come up and present his or her views and
then at the end we'll after we've had
our chance up here we'll give you your
chance out there and we'll have a fun
time of questions and answers from the
audience from each other on the on the
panel here and so I think you'll have a
a great afternoon with that and the
other thing I will tell you is because
you have these these four experts have
some very impressive backgrounds and
those are all well written up in the in
the booklets you have and so I'm not
going to take time to describe that I'll
spend our time on on discussions and
questions and the answers so with that
I'd like to turn over the podium to
Admiral Bill chyme comment down to the
Coast Guard president of society and
naval architects and marine engineers
thanks Hank and I greatly appreciate the
opportunity to come back up to MIT where
I spent three very happy years and the
further I get from graduation the happy
the years seem to be
I last had a chance to come up and give
one of the Robert Bruce Wallace lectures
in 1991 and I'm surprised you invited me
back maybe all the people who were there
have have moved on let me ask you a
question why are we here discussing oil
spill issues why is this something
that's on people's mind I think one
reason is the Exxon Valdez obviously
that woke up this country to the
concerns of oil spill certainly woke up
the Congress to pass OPA 90 after a
gestation period of about 15 years but
let me give you some of the other
reasons why we're concerned we've got
five percent of the population in this
country and we use over twenty percent
of the energy as a country we're against
offshore drilling we're against opening
up the Anwar we don't like nuclear power
we hate to carpool we won't use or say
we don't have mass transportation that
means we're going to continue to import
at an ever-increasing rate greater
amounts of oil by ship and about 95
percent of this is going to come on
foreign flight tankers and as a result
of that spills are going to continue to
occur so I think the issue is what can
we do to minimize their probability and
to maximize the effectiveness of our
response when they do happen I think
this is something that is going to
require the major dedication and
cooperation of many people ship
designers ship builders ship owners ship
charters ship brokers ship owned ships
crews classification societies the
insurance industry the P&I clubs flag
States support States and certainly the
oil companies how are we going to to do
this I think we're going to do it by
effectively addressing five areas of
concern one and one of the most
important the prevention of a spill in
the first place our preparedness to
respond to spills
once they do occur how we actually do
respond the question of liability for
the Spiller and then finally
compensation for those people who are
impacted by the spells and the
restoration of of the environment now
ideally we would do this internationally
through the IMO the International
Maritime Organization which is a
specialized agency of the United Sates
and environmental treaties are
negotiated the IMO is located in London
and I believe they have about 140 member
countries right now however some
problems in in the past have led to
unilateral action by the United States
and as Hank Marcus said the Oil
Pollution Act of 1990
now Congress didn't just jump on the Oil
Pollution Act of 1990 they've been
working on this for about 15 years
and there's been a lot of discussions
about doing many of the things that are
contained in the Oil Pollution Act for
many many years while they're 535
members in the Congress and as Hank
pointed out no naval architects they
they do have a memory and they do
recognize that the industry itself did
not respond in what they felt was a
reasonable way to incidences that has
that have occurred certainly we've cut
down the operational pollution from
tankers we've cut down the accidental
pollution from tankers but by the same
token I think we're faced with a society
right now that is more demanding and
less forgiving for incidences OPA 90 was
unilateral action by the United States
and that same type of unilateral action
is threatened right now perhaps even
imminently by the European community and
by the UK in particular due to the fact
that IMO standards in the past take too
long
to be developed take too long to come
into force or they're ambiguous or they
represent the least common denominator
and they're not enforced in many cases
so my belief is that IMO is still the
vehicle to attacked all aspects of oil
spills but if we don't through IMO
eliminate substandard ships substandard
crews substandard owners substandard
insurance companies substandard
regulations substandard enforcement
which i think is the biggest problem
substandard flag states and substandard
port states unilateral action led by the
United States and the EC is going to
become the rule let's look in some
detail at each important area
concerning oil spills first prevention
second preparedness third response then
liability and compensation and follow it
up with question of enforcement
there are many international conventions
that deal with the subject the safety of
life at sea convention our solace the
treaty to prevent pollution from ships
or MARPOL OPR c90 the oil pollution
preparedness response and cooperation
treaty protocols to the Civil Liability
Convention and the fund convention the
Convention on standards of training
certification and watchkeeping all of
these done by the Maritime Safety
Committee of the International Maritime
Organization and the Environmental
Protection Committee there's also a new
subcommittee they're called FSI which is
the flight state implementation
subcommittee that has recently been put
into place and i'll also referred to a
new code the international safety
management code that we hope to bring
into force at the IMO assembly and in
October now going to prevention first
that's covered in many aspects by the
STCW convention by soleus Marple
and the international safety management
code let's look at some of the specific
areas that need a bit more attention we
spent a lot of time in STCW talking
about training of people aboard ship if
you were a chief engineer if you were
the cargo officer if you were the master
this is what training you had to have
but it is totally silent and the
maritime community is yet to face up to
the issue of things such as minimum
level of Manning crew fatigue the amount
of time you can spend on the ship team
training in 1995 the secretary-general
of IMO mr. Bill O'Neil has set this as a
date for a significant revision of STCW
hopefully we will finally come to grips
with these issues if you ask me the
reason we haven't it's easy to talk
about training doesn't cost a whole lot
to talk about it when you start setting
Manning standards and and hours that
people can work in fatigue standards
that starts to cost a great deal of
money for prevention we need vessel
traffic systems we've just looked at 23
ports in the United States and they're
going to be phasing in vessel traffic
systems very similar to the type of air
control that you see in the nations
Airways we'll be using things such as
dependent surveillance where ship will
pick up a Global Positioning System
signal from a satellite
it'll be corrected by differential
mechanism to give it an accuracy of
about 8 meters and translate transmit
that back to a Coast Guard control
facility we're going to be requiring tug
escorts in certain areas like in already
in Prince William Sound Puget Sound and
San Francisco Bay we're going to see
coming this summer a requirement that
when in the u.s. navigable waters which
means anything from 3 miles in to deck
officers on the bridge an engineer in
the engine room no matter how automated
the ship is and automatic pilot ships
will not be able to operate
in these navigable waters except under
certain circumstances they're gonna be
tanker exclusion zone zones where
tankers will not be allowed at all we're
going to talk about ship construction
and Hank said that double bottoms double
hulls may not be the answer to a
Maiden's prayer but certainly they are
going to go a long way towards
preventing a lot of the pollution we
have some people say things like the
mid-deck design or vacuum designs are
things that we ought to move toward but
we haven't seen anything any real ship
being built that way even any large
scale models and we talked about
Congress using performance standards for
cars and we see on TV pictures of
Volvo's and BMWs being driven into brick
walls you can't do that with a heavy
industry you've got to be a bit more
prescriptive sometime where the industry
if they want to get out from under
specific regulations the Congress is
going to have to come forward with more
in the area of research and development
one thing that's very encouraging to me
is the damage resistant Hall study
that's being done by MIT there's 11
contributors to this project one of
which is the Coast Guard it's paying
about sixth about 15% of the funding
this is the kind of thing I think we
need more of if we want to keep the
Congress from acting shift to
preparedness and there it's the OPR C
Convention it's parallel in the United
States again as OPA 90 because OPA 90
kind of covers all of the areas of
concern of these international treaties
requires a National Response plan for
pollution that's being revised right now
to be published shortly area response
plans the Coast Guard has established a
national strike force Coordination
Center and three strike teams that will
be able to respond to a spill and also
to provide for training not only for
Coast Guard people but for others and
there's a simulation going on right now
as we speak here in the Boston area
there's going to be a requirement for
pre-positioned equipment the Coast Guard
is established pre position equipments
in 19 sites
the country that we selected on the
basis of need past experience type of
cargo moved through the ports and
finally shipping terminals are going to
have to have response plans approved by
the Coast Guard they had to be submitted
by the 18th of February and you have to
operate under these plans by the 18th of
August or you can't operate a ship or a
terminal in US waters and this is going
to require that there be designated
individuals to be in charge 24 hours a
day should a spill occur and that you
identify and have under contract
pollution response equipment leading us
into response again internationally it's
the OU PRC and there we're going to
utilize the items I just mentioned the
equipment and the planning we also have
other things that we need to do a better
job in tho and utilization in in
response one is dispersants as a country
we have never been able to come to grips
with the use of dispersants the Torrey
Canyon was a major oil spill incident
off the coast of England and the British
response to it was to soap up the entire
Atlantic Ocean using significance
exorbitant amount of dispersants doing
probably more damage with the
dispersants than it was done by the oil
that caused in the United States a great
relaxed reluctance to use dispersants
we've never brought this back to an even
keel there are many cases where
dispersants can be used but we can't get
behind beyond the political stigma of
them the scientific community can't come
to grips with it local elected officials
who have veto and this cannot face up to
the political realities there are cases
where dispersants could be used and
aren't we need to come to grips with
this bioremediation another area where
you provide nitrogen to existing
microorganisms in the oil that will
accelerate the degradation of the oil by
the microd microorganisms we certainly
use this in Alaska I spent three weeks
in Alaska as a federal on-scene
coordinator responding to the Exxon
Valdez spill we there we saw
bioremediation being used very well very
safely but again the same political
concerns about
that so we can't get the maximum use out
of it and set you burning we can't get a
permit from the EPA
even though funding is available to do
testing to see if burning the oil
on-site once it's in the water and then
measuring the effects in the water
column in the air to see if this isn't
more beneficial than letting the oil
come ashore we can't get a permit to do
that
mechanical cleanup skimmers booms things
of that nature we're in the T model Ford
stage in that particular area
Opa ninety wanted research in these
areas authorized a significant amount of
money US Coast Guard is the only federal
agency that is sought and received money
from the Congress to do research in this
area this is an area that we need a
tremendous amount of cooperative effort
both nationally and internationally now
finally we can talk about liability and
compensation and there are two
international conventions that provide
for this the CLC and fund Convention
it's a two tiered approach the CLC
Convention the civil liability
convention provides that the ship owner
has the first tier he's the one that can
keep the oil from spilling he has
liability up to a certain level and then
for spills that are in excess of that
country's based on the amount of oil
they produce or import contribute a
certain amount to an international fund
that would take care of the very very
large case the United States did not
sign this convention because these
limits of liability from a practical
basis were much too low in 1984 their
protocols were developed internationally
that raised these levels significantly
but the United States did not ratify
these protocols we didn't because ship
owners and the oil companies torpedoed
the US efforts to ratify they hoped that
they could use existing voluntary funds
called tavola and krystal instead well
they were fooled instead they got OPA 90
which had many features they don't like
now there is unn
liability no preemption of states it's
easier to break what limits of liability
you have again we got to where we are by
the reluctance of responsible people to
take responsible action now OPA ninety
has as its its premise in this area that
the Spiller pays the Spiller meaning the
ship owner pays first they pay quickly
and they pay with certainty for cleanup
compensation and restoration of the
environment as a result of this the
Coast Guard has set up the national
pollution fund center which manages a 1
billion dollar trust fund money accrue
to this monies accrue to this from a 5
cent a barrel 5 cents for every 42
gallons of oil either produced or
imported into the United States we're
almost at the 1 billion dollar level
right now
that is takes the place of the
international fund convention there is a
liability for a ship owner of $1200 per
ton as the the first level this is about
a hundred and fifty million dollars in
liability for the owner of a very large
accrued carrier the ship owner also has
to prove that he does have the assets to
meet this liability and because of the
nature of OPA 90 and the fact that we
did not ratify the CLC and fund
protocols of 1984 it has been very
difficult to get this insurance
something we're working on I think
internationally this is probably the
major problem facing shipping and
insurance right now we're hopeful with
some meetings coming up in Washington
with the insurance and shipping
industries in early July we can get
around this but again we're where we are
because we didn't take responsible
action in the past now finally to talk
about enforcement the flag state
implementation subcommittee met for the
first time about a month ago in London
and came up with some requirements we
are seeing a proliferation of flag
States now states that have no
infrastructure but are flagging ships
under their flag claiming there
international conventions they have no
knowledge in their government to say
that in fact these ships meet these
standards they then delegate this to a
classification society we have a very
great proliferation of classification
societies now not the norske veritas is
the American Bureau of shipping and the
Lloyds registers of the world that we're
used to but once again that have no real
infrastructure no nothing behind it no
surveyors dedicated adjust to them so
we're seeing the parts of a safety net
we're seeing more owners that are banks
that are management companies not the
old time ship owners that that we see
have seen in the past so what we're
seeing is ships falling through a series
of safety nets the owner not being
responsible hopefully the new
international safety management code
will help a great deal in that next is
the flag state not being responsible
I am always passed a resolution that
will vote on in London and October to
provide standards of what you should be
to be a flag state consum countries
developing countries say it's their
god-given right to have a commercial
fleet of their own and the shipping
industry is willing to go to that
because control is less taxes or less
and they can hire just about anybody
they want to as as a crew well that does
it's fine as long as they stay in their
own waters but when they come into other
waters there's certain requirements they
have to meet the IMO is going to pass a
resolution to say what they are
classification societies up until now
there's been nothing to define what IMO
and treaties call a recognized
classification society that is going to
change with a resolution saying what it
is let me say I'm very pleased that the
classification societies under their
international Association I acts are
putting together a self auditing medic
mechanism under ISO 9000 to see what
their level of quality is the IMO is
participating in this
unfortunately the insurance companies
who have complained
about the work of the classification
societies have not seen fit to join in
although it's been requested and the
classification societies have offered to
to pay the the money then finally we
have the insurance companies who in the
past I think have not taken a
responsible look at insurance of ships
if you drive a car today you pay on the
basis of whether you're male female how
old you are whether you're married what
route you drive what zip code you house
your car in much insurance for ships in
the past was just based on it being a
ship ship to their credit insurance
companies are now starting to take a
much closer look at this but I think the
thing boils down to the first safety net
that we're talking about if we want to
keep Opie a 90 from happening and that
is respond the responsibility of the
owner and the crew of the vessel because
if they do what they're supposed to do
none of these other safety nets come
into play what I've tried to do is give
you an overview of what I see the issues
are how we got to where we are now and
some of the things that I think we need
to do in the future to improve it so we
keep our 537 35 members of the US
Congress from again writing the types of
law that Hank indicated perhaps they
shouldn't thank you very much
[Applause]
Thank You Admiral for getting us off to
a great start our next speaker is a
palma nandus amber eCos chairman of
amber eco shipbrokers limited and
delighted he could come here from London
to be with us and we're looking forward
to your comments professor Marcus ladies
and gentlemen a key goal of the Oil
Pollution Act of 1990 was to reduce oil
pollution to the maximum extent possible
it is ironic therefore that certain
provisions of the Act inadvertently tend
to have the very opposite effect
these same provisions are also harmful
to US interests in other respects I
shall seek to explain why this is so and
I shall outline a possible remedy which
would address some of the defects of the
Act and thereby render its goal more
attainable it may help if at this
juncture I made some comment about some
of the relevant provisions of the Act
for those who are not familiar with them
under prior law ship owners had the
right to limit their liability for
pollution damages pursuant to the
limitation of Liability Act of 1850 one
open 90 eliminated that right for all
claims arising out of oil spill
incidents liability for an oil spill
under the Act is on a strict liability
no-fault basis in other words a ship
owner is liable if oil spills from his
vessel even though he and his servants
were in no way at fault the ship owner
is liable for example even though the
fault may have been that of a u.s. pilot
open 90 furthermore expressly eliminated
preemption of state law by federal law
for oil spill incidents thereby
permitting states to adopt their own oil
spill liability regimes many of which
now provide for
Limited Liability although in theory
open 90 still gives the ship owner the
right to limit his liability under
federal law albeit at higher levels this
right is in fact illusory since limits
under the Act are very easy to break
thereby leading to what is in effect
unlimited liability thus since OPA 90
came into force a ship owner trading to
the USA is faced with a prospect of
unlimited liability in the case of an
oil spill this fact must be seen in the
context of the potential costs of oil
spills in the United States the Exxon
Valdez oil spill cost Exxon well in
excess of two billion dollars and this
of course was before open 19 and the
broader definition of environmental
damage which pertains today we now come
to the nub of the matter unlimited
liability is uninsurable
in fact the maximum insurance that is
available to a ship owner today for oil
pollution liabilities is 700 million
dollars any ship owner who chooses to
trade to the States today does so on a
seriously underinsured basis the under
insurance is so severe when compared to
the potential multi-billion dollar
liabilities that in the case of a
serious oil spill a ship owner is to all
intents and purposes trading uninsured
furthermore the uninsured liabilities
are of a magnitude that Dwarfs the net
worth of even a large ship owner not
only is the owner uninsured however but
he is in a jurisdiction where the courts
have a propensity to seek to pierce the
corporate veil thus in effect the United
States is inviting those ship owners who
service her knee
to come and play Russian roulette tanker
owners are of course most at risk but
all ship owners are exposed for example
any vessel can be in collision with the
tanker thereby exposing her owner to
unlimited liability under state law the
collision between a bulk carrier and the
British Trent is but the recent example
of the potential danger I put it to you
that these are not desirable
consequences that one would expect to
flow from a responsible well-thought-out
law this state of affairs should be
contrasted with today's international
regime where limitation of liability is
fully recognized at levels well within
the bounds of available insurance cover
bear in mind that US trade today depends
on foreign vessels 80 percent of US
petroleum imports are carried by foreign
ship owners the consequences of open 90
are predictable responsible owners will
either be driven from US trades or
alternatively they will be encouraged to
behave irresponsibly I know that some
say that open 90 has succeeded in as
much as the world shipping community has
continued trading to the US that however
is a short-sighted view the very large
volume of US imports and exports makes
it impossible for ship owners to
withdraw from US trades in the short run
after all they have acquired vessels on
the basis of the existing volume of
world trade and they have no alternative
today but to employ those vessels I
shall tell you however what is currently
happening and how matters will evolve
ship owners are avoiding ordering the
types of vessel
which would need to trade to us
destinations such as for example Suez
Maks tankers future US trade will be
affected accordingly the problem is
further compounded by open nineties
provisions which require that new
building tankers must have double hulls
double hulls are a good pollution
preventing design in the case of low
impact groundings or collisions they
increase the likelihood of a
catastrophic oil spill however in the
case of a high impact grounding or
collision this is because the empty
uninvited tanks make capsizing and
explosion more likely Exxon carried out
a study after the Exxon Valdez grounding
and concluded that had the vessel being
of double hull design she would have
capsized and lost all her cargo the
double bottom to Aegean Sea exploded
shortly after grounding with a loss of
all her cargo the Merce navigator was
involved in a collision and was struck
in way of a segregated ballast tank she
was in effect double-hulled in that area
she promptly exploded the empty tank
resulted in greater instead of less
pollution these accidents should be
contrasted with the grounding of the
brer in the Shetlands the Bria was of
conventional single hull design and even
though after grounding she was buffeted
and pounded for days by hurricane and
gale force winds she did not explode of
course she finally broke up but had a
salvage operation being possible earlier
most of her cargo would have been saved
the reality of the situation is that
ship owners are required by OPA 90 to
build double hulled vessels for the US
trades
in the full knowledge that in the case
of an accident this type of vessel is
more likely to lead to a catastrophic
oil spill for which the owner will be
liable and for which you'll be uninsured
thus resulting in his ruin it is not
surprising therefore the chip owners are
not queuing up to build 100
million-dollar VLC C's when they know
that not only can they lose their
investment but be bankrupted to boot if
an oil spill occurs all this does not
augur well for the future servicing of
US trade there is developing a trend of
long term disinvestment in the types of
vessel required for US trade even
assuming however which I do not that
serious ship owners will continue in the
future to trade to and from the US open
90 does not serve American interests
well in as much as some of its
provisions are inimical to its key aim
the reduction of oil pollution it is
axiomatic that the business man involved
in a high-risk business will be acting
irresponsibly if he operates
substantially uninsured to create a
situation where he is bound to do so
cannot but breed a responsibility if
ship owners are forced to act
irresponsibly in this way it is
unrealistic to expect them to act
responsibly in every other way yet to
avoid oil pollution responsible behavior
needs to be encouraged not discouraged
it is never wise to demand the
performance of the impossible ship
owners trading to the States will be
either discouraged and despondent or
they will have an indifferent fatalistic
could not care less attitude in either
case
the likelihood of oil spills is
increased perhaps more importantly
however it seems to me that where the
potential uninsured losses are not only
vast but are also third party
liabilities the government has a duty as
a matter of public policy to ensure that
insurance is not only available but is
also compulsory one would not expect the
government to condone motorists driving
their cars without insurance yet those
liabilities are minut compared to
potential oil pollution liabilities the
United States should as a matter of
public policy not permit the situation
to him to exist in which all her
petroleum imports are carried by
substantially underinsured vessels let
alone to create such a situation this
brings me to the remedy the US
government should require that all
tankers trading to the states carry
insurance to a very high level say two
billion dollars compulsory insurance to
such a level is necessary to avoid the
situation in which those ship owners who
take out such insurance become
uncompetitive and are driven from the US
trades by other less responsible owners
who are willing to take a chance and
trade on a substantially underinsured
basis understanding that the market may
not be able to provide capacity up to
say two billion dollars in short order
the higher mandatory amount may need to
be phased in over a period of time from
the currently available 700 million
dollars the mandatory nature of the
insurance creating a sufficient premium
base to allow higher levels of insurance
to become commercially available in due
course
alternatively the federal government
should mandate a supplemental insurance
regime similar to that currently under
consideration for the aviation industry
in the proposed legislation implementing
the Montreal protocols the premiums
should be charged on a per voyage basis
enabling the ship owner to pass them on
down the chain and thus ensuring that a
proper level of premium can be paid for
the necessary cover to be made available
in this way the main defect of open 90
that of the uninsurable liabilities it
created would be largely addressed and
the Act would be strengthened
significantly there would be another
benefit as well currently to the extent
that ship owners are underinsured all
uninsured cleanup costs or claims
associated with an oil spill will be
paid by the federal government from the
1 billion dollar federal oil spill
liability trust fund created pursuant to
OPA thus the federal government has a
direct and immediate interest in all
ship owners having adequate insurance
cover nevertheless there is I understand
some reluctance to tinker with open if
that is a legitimate concern the remedy
which I have suggested could equally
well be achieved by free-standing
legislation proposals along these lines
have been made by the international
shipping community as long ago as
January 1992 but surprisingly a response
from the US government is still awaited
there is yet the further aspect of OPA
which is relevant and is worth
mentioning the scope of OPA includes
all damage claims both public and
private arising from an oil spill and
permits all claimants to pursue direct
action against the ship owners
ability insurers open 90 was intended in
addition to minimizing oil pollution to
provide an effective response and
compensation system in cases of oil
spills financial responsibility is a
central component of the Act tanker
owners trading to the US must have
certificates of financial responsibility
to cover an amount up to their
theoretical limit of liability which
certificates must be subject to the
direct action provisions of the Act the
marine insurers that cover a ship owners
third party liabilities known as
protection and indemnity clubs when
faced with the expanded scope of
liability under OPA both with respect to
limits and claimants have not
surprisingly refused to provide the
necessary certificates interestingly
enough no u.s. insurer and certainly no
other foreign insurer is willing to
provide these certificates either
without the backing of their insurers
practically no ship owners have access
to financial resources sufficient to
obtain certificates of financial
responsibility without these
certificates ships cannot enter US ports
open 90 therefore created the real risk
that US trade would grind to a halt
faced with this dilemma the Coast Guard
understandably has delayed promulgating
the regulations implementing open 90 in
this respect while it searches for a
solution a solution has been put forward
by the International shipping community
which has proposed that the government
mandated supplemental insurance facility
which I referred to before be subject to
direct action and provide the backing
necessary for the issuance of
certificates of financial responsibility
yet the problem is still with us
a solution to the question of
certificates of financial responsibility
will have to be found in seeking such a
solution the Coast Guard has the
opportunity also to solve the much
larger but related problem of inadequate
insurance which places both ship owners
and the US government in serious
financial jeopardy and leaves the
environment at risk we must hope
therefore that this issue will be
addressed in the near future both by the
administration and by the Congress thank
you thank you very much for that ship
owners perspective I think it's safe to
say we'll have an interesting question
and answer period stay tuned next we
have Richard quakin general manager
Marine Department texaco to give us an
oil company's perspective
I couldn't good afternoon um it's a
pleasure being here top being alumnus of
MIT I think I'm one of the only people
walking around with a badge of a known
number and somebody asked me why there
wasn't a number I said I was still
working on my degree after 35 years but
I'm here to talk about the oil spill
issues of the day and if you could turn
the sides on please
as of where we stand in June 1993 I'm
going to talk from an oil company
perspective both as the cargo owner and
as a tanker owner ourselves we like most
major oil companies operate our own
fleet we do a considerable amount of
chartering with independent owners and
I'll brief you bring you through a
little history to tell you how we got
where we are today what we see is some
of the problems and some of the things
are going to have to do I will refer to
open 90 but I won't dwell on it since
it's been covered so extensively by our
previous two speakers the tanker
industry and specifically the oil
company segment of that industry is in
fact an industry entrant in transition
the changes in the oil industry itself
in terms of ownership of the oil
location refineries location of
production increasing regulation of
whatnot have changed the role of the
Marine departments to tanker departments
of the of the various companies one of
the things that brought us to a
situation we're in today is the history
of oil movements in the world by tanker
in the past 20 or so years 30 years as
you see the oil movements peaked in the
early 70s at a time where everybody was
afraid that wouldn't be enough oil to
last to the end of the century and where
prices were creeping up towards 35 to 40
dollars a barrel with projections that
oil would cost as much as a hundred a
hundred thousand a hundred dollars a
barrel by the 90s the conservation
methods that kicked in as a result of
that high price brought a drastic
reduction particularly in the Middle
East the blue segment of the chart which
is the long haul segment of our oil
industry resulting in the early 80s of a
depression in tankers principally
because the industry reacted to that
projected increase of oil movements like
undertaking a tremendous building
program particularly in the very large
crude carrier the independent seeing the
need by the oil companies to move that
oil join the oil companies in this
building org orgy a lot of the tankers
that were built by the independence
we're in fact taking on charter term
charter as long as twenty years by the
oil companies in 1978-79 the major oil
companies that were therefore controlled
about 60% of the tankers either through
ownership or a long-term charter that
were plying the oceans routes again as
the demand fell off at rather severe
depression that lasted through the 1980s
developed in the tanker industry because
there were just too many bottoms chasing
too few cargoes that lasted right
through the end of the 80s when briefly
a a somewhat healthy resurgence took
place as the supply and demand of
tankers became more imbalance that
unfortunately resulted in another wave
of new buildings thereby increasing the
number of avails and resulting in 1992
being a very depressed year as you can
see the construction of tankers peaked
in the mid to late 70s with the
depression the order book literally
dried up a good part of the world's
shipbuilding capacity virtually
disappeared in Japan about 30 to 35
percent of the shipbuilding capacity was
actually destroyed in Europe many of the
major shipbuilding companies are no
longer in the business as the depression
went through the 80s the number of
scrapping is increased dramatically
we in fact Texaco scrapped VL CCS that
were less than 10 years old that we have
built for twenty-five to thirty million
dollars and just turned him into razor
blades for about four to five million
dollars but we had to do it because they
were all sitting in mothballs rusting
away
as we got into this little healthy
period in the late 80s again the was a
minor resurgence but a significant
enough resurgence in new buildings and
equally importantly a almost
disappearance of the scrapping resulting
in a current continued oversupply of
tankers this is reflected in recent
years in the freight rates that are paid
to the tanker owner either the oil
company owner or by the oil company to
the independent in 1990 we were fairly
healthy the blue line represents a V LCC
going from the Persian Gulf West either
to Europe or to the US Gulf the red line
is a Caribbean to the US 30 thousand ton
product carrier and you can see the
effect on Operation Desert Storm in the
late 1990s it didn't last 92 became a
disastrous year for not only the
independence but the Marine functions of
the major oil companies and today the
major oil companies controlled directly
about 20% of the tankers compared to the
60% I referred to in 1973 they Charter
in on a voyage basis a single voyage
basis perhaps another 15 percent so as
we go through this brief chat keep in
mind that the influence the oil
companies have on the tanker industry
has diminished significantly over the
past 20 years with greater influence
going to oil producing companies
countries who tend to move their own oil
the oil traders unfortunately over the
my lifetime in the industry which is
over 30 years now there have been a
series of accidents that have
dramatically caught the public's
attention and starting with the Torrey
Canyon was probably the first one off
the south coast of the UK that was the
first big spill that was the first
tanker that broke up that was of a size
that really could spill a great deal of
oil the Amoco Cadiz and locally the Argo
merchant in the late 70s again caught
the public's attention as to the risks
that was entailed
with tankers carrying oil into the
United States or into Europe and most
dramatically the Exxon Valdez in 1989
has changed our lives in the industry
forever given that referred to I think
by Hank before tanker accidents caused a
very small portion of the oil that makes
its way into the environment on an
annual basis the greatest single source
of oil is the industrial sewage type of
disposal an environmentalist told me at
one point that there was the equivalent
of approximately 20 Exxon Valdez going
into the environment every year by
people dumping lube oil into the sewer
into the ground tank of operations the
bunker spills less than scrupulous
owners discharging oil over the side at
night type of thing again represents a
fairly small part but a significant part
of those tanker accidents statistics
have shown continually that over 80% of
the accidents are caused by human
failure and I suspect that some of the
other categories such as equipment and
structural is indirectly a result of
human failure which tells us that this
is where we have to look one of the
unfortunate aspects of the OPA in terms
of the financial cost is that it is
extremely expensive in terms of reacting
to a spill and I don't think nearly
enough directed towards the prevention
of a spill through training and
certification of Mariners the Oil
Pollution Act as again previously stated
the tax or tax addresses on those at 40
and slip I think addresses several
aspects of tanker operations certainly
the construction through double hulls
tanker safety through licensing the
pollution liability which has been
talked about contingency plans and I'll
refer back to this later because this is
one of the positive areas I think that
has come out of the the act and
financial responsibility which is has
has been said it's certainly currently
the nuttiest problem we have
I'm trying to resolve this this issue
Texaco and the the oil industry the
tanker industry within the oil industry
likes to talk in terms of the four PS
that we have to adopt in order to
address the current situation one of the
things we have to realize and we do
realize it's not the same game that it
was five years ago ten years ago or 20
years ago the world as far as we are
concerned has changed and we have to
recognize it and change with it
prevention protection participation and
perception prevention we have to do what
is necessary to prevent the accident
from having recurring occurred in the
first place I mean you talk about the
billions of dollars required to clean up
a spill we have to concentrate on not
having that spill in the first place one
of the ways is through proper
maintenance of ships one of the results
of that those previous graphs you saw on
building and scrapping is that the
average age of the world tanker fleet is
getting old the great bulk of the VL CC
capacity was built in the 70s and is
approaching 20 years old now the sea is
a very hostile environment as many of
you know it's a very corrosive
environment in terms of the salt dlc
seas rounding Cape of Good Hope
continually year after year taking a
fairly good stress and strain as going
through the heavy seas in that area of
the world it's absolutely imperative
that companies address the maintenance
of their tankers to make sure they are
up to the absolute best condition
possible again as Admiral Cain referred
to earlier we are working very strongly
with the classification societies to
increase the inspections of ships to
increase the renewal the rate of renewal
on steel to make everybody come up with
the maintenance maintenance possible
training I think that there's no
substitute for training this particular
slide shows a firefighting school at
Texas A&M University at Texaco and other
shipping companies not only oil
companies use again you may have heard
in the paper yesterday on
the explosion of the British Trent BP
product tanker carrying gasoline that
reportedly collided with a non tanker
immediately exploded all 30 yacht crew
member had to abandon ship immediately
22 or 23 may have survived fire is the
thing that is dreaded and most poor
tanker there's no place to go when
there's a fire unless you put it out but
this type of training has the added
advantage not only of teaching how to
people to react to a crisis aboard ship
but it instills in the individuals a
consciousness of safety a chief made
master those skills that are necessary
to react to to operate a ship these
courses which last a week are basically
crises courses we teach ship management
team bridge bridge team work the passage
planning the the ability to get the ship
from A to B trying to anticipate all
possible contingencies and then as the
exercise is going on throwing in some
unexpected development as just as going
between a breakwaters the captain has a
heart attack and the chief mate has to
take over does he know what to do how to
do it
a ship that has radioed that it's going
to act in a certain way acts in a
different way by doing this on a
simulator obviously we get the benefit
of the the experience without going
through the real thing which we never
want to do the crews on the ships are
becoming increasingly important again go
back to the 80% man power failure we
firmly believe in Texaco and other
majors that the Manning is becoming
increasingly critical to prevent
accidents we hire crews on a permanent
basis and otherwise have become
employees of the company we go through
training this is a photograph happens to
be of our newest tanker the star Ohio at
double-hulled 150,000 ton crude carrier
delivered in Korea last October D Todd
the officers are Italian nationals the
senior officers have been with Texaco
over 20 years and the junior officers
proportionally went the time the
Filipino crew have been with us for
several years
we're proud that there's less than a 5%
turnover among the Filipino group and
we're proud of that because we spend a
lot of money on training the crew we
don't only concentrate on the officers
well we certainly focus on them very
strongly but we also train the crew and
it's important we feel that we develop
this sense of loyalty to the company
that the same individuals will keep
coming back working as a team and
working together one of the things that
we do in our inspection program and we
like many other majors have an
inspection program or we actually
physically go aboard an independent ship
and put it through a rather rigorous
inspection before we will utilize the
ship one of the things we're focusing on
more and more again as demanding
policies in that depressed market in
1992 for an independent and not all of
them did it but some did enough to cause
a problem if you if you have a lower
income the quickest way you can reduce
your cost is lower maintenance and go
after the cheapest possible crew you can
find that several of the ships that were
had recent accidents we turned down on
inspection because we felt that the
owner had compromised too much on his
Manning and in effect was hiring casual
labor and we just felt this was totally
unacceptable we will continue to find it
totally unacceptable protection we
accept we have an enormous
responsibility to protect the
environment to protect the national
region a chiral resources not only of
the United States but of the world we do
a lot of drills aboard ship this happens
to be a abandon ship drill with
protective gear but we do firefighting
drills simulated drills of individuals
getting caught in enclosed spaces about
not and through the constant drilling
again we attempt to instill the spirit
of safety the thought of safety
throughout the crew we know the
environment is our responsibility by the
way put that slide in because when I
went to sea with the thing I used to
love to do when going through the South
Atlantic or the Pacific Ocean was stand
on a bow and watch the dolphins
kind of raced up ahead of the ships that
smell us for me the industry has funded
to the tune of 1 billion dollars the
nsrc spill response corporation this is
a corporation that it has been set up it
is run by X Coast Guard officers it has
been equipped with about a half a
billion dollars worth of equipment in
terms of Skinner skimmers barges and
whatnot it will be and it is in the
process of being strategically located
to complement the Coast Guard's
capability around the country it will be
available in the event of a major spill
it is going to be I believe a Cadillac
spill response capability and one that
hopefully will never have to use
participation we have to recognize in
the industry I think we have recognized
that again as things have changed over
the years we're not so much a private
business as we were we have partners the
US Coast Guard in the United States is
certainly becoming a partner in our
business in Internet and internationally
regulatory agencies throughout the world
are one of the good things I refer to an
OPA when the Coast Guard was required to
prepare regulations for contingency
planning aboard tanker tankers they
invited through a regulatory negotiation
process the Reg neck process all
segments of the industry to sit around
the table environmentalists unions oil
companies independent ship owners spill
response companies state government
representations and over a period of
several months with a great deal of
difficulty I might add
they reached a consensus on what should
be the capability of a tanker to respond
to a environmental incident incident in
the United States to contracting for
spill equipment defining what is the
logical or likely spill it didn't make
anybody totally happy I don't believe
but it made everybody partially happy
which is probably as good as you could
get into under the circumstance but I do
recommend the Coast Guard again when
the results of the Reg neg have been
questioned or attacked by members of
Congress for their own particular
reasons the Coast Guard has stood out
very strongly and defended to process
and defended the regulations we also
have to recognize those oil company
charterers and owners that we have
partners in terms of the independence
the oil companies have been in the past
and across the board been accused of
having a certain amount of arrogance and
I think that was true we will tell you
what to do we'll tell you how to do and
that's that's it otherwise we don't work
with you but I think now we do really
have to work with the independent owner
these concerns that we have about safety
and Manning and training we have to work
with the independent holder to make sure
that we feed him what we can in our
experience and on the other hand are
satisfied that the owner was doing what
he can to meet those requirements we
have to be partners with the regulatory
societies at the classification
societies again we all have to work
together or we're all going to go down
together and perception the perception
of the oil industry in general and the
tanker industry specifically is a very
very poor one there's absolutely no
tension made by the media or the public
to the millions of millions of millions
of barrels that are transported safely
every day in and out of the US and
around the world in and out of Boston
for that example without incident the
amount is phenomenal yet when we do have
an accident we get from page press and
evening news shots and the perception is
negative we would like perception to be
this and this is what our this is what
our goal is and I frankly see no reason
why it can't be I mean we those of us
have gone to see whether it's in a
Merchant Marine the Navy the Coast Guard
or private boats alumni you know love
the sea it's our livelihood
I spent some of the happiest years of my
life selling both on yachts and then on
in the Navy and on tankers and I will do
anything to prevent damage to the sea
and I the industry has that feeling our
problem is that we are unable to get
that across
public and through for our sisters this
this is what we were attempting to do
again even though the slide shows a very
calm sea with a beautiful sunset
somewhere in the mid ocean we recognize
that there are a lot of problems ahead a
wise captain once told me something I
never forgot he asked me when I was on
watch a second mate where the nearest
land was and I very smartly pointed to
an island that was about 15 miles off
our port bow and he said no it's right
under you I never forgot that so even
though we see a column see how we know
that there's a lot of reefs and problems
there and we're working very diligently
to try to avoid them and trying to work
with you and with the government to
provide a safer environment for all of
us thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Nikki for the oil
company perspective batting cleanup
today we have Lisa Martinez and it's
always a delight for me to share the
podium with a former student Thank You
Hank I'm supposed to be the cleanup and
ironically I'm the only one on this crew
that has never been involved with an oil
spill cleanup so the cleanup is purely a
figure of speech I'm also supposed to
provide the broadening influence in the
context so four starts let me wave in
your general direction a 1926 US
government report entitled oil pollution
of navigable waters
so my first element of context is time
though we fret about this this is not an
absolutely new problem it's one which we
think we have solved a number of times
and my comments are essentially going to
tell you from my point of view as I
represent no organization other than
myself and my computer
what I find tolerable what I find in
tolerable and what my biases wire will
become immediately clear my first
context parameter we're going to use
these MIT words is oil spills in the
context of issues facing marine
transportation it's not the most
important problem we have and I can
barely tolerate the constant attention
that oil spills get by several measures
we have far more egregious situations
facing this industry and by example I
will give you the events of January 1993
which I looked up in a fairly reputable
series of journals the Braer 1993
Shetland's no crew lost all crew rescued
cargo total loss vessel total breakup
the Cody one have you ever heard of it a
cement carrier went down
with all hands the same week as the
brayer the I can't even pronounce this
up yon feuless hue elicits a Polish flag
RORO cargo went down over fifty people
died these were all events in the same
month but I would I would conjecture
that to the public the only one that's
recognizable as a marine casualty was a
prayer even though there was no loss of
life as a member of this profession I
find that distortion really intolerable
on any kind of a permanent basis the
other effect that this has as a member
of the profession is that it distorts
and I use these words quite deliberately
the way you get to work in this
profession oil spills attract a lot of
attention but there's only a limited
number of maritime professionals there's
only a limited number of naval
architects and therefore other problems
go waiting or go unnoticed even though
we have the statistics that should drive
that work to tell us that those are the
more important things for us to work on
the other kind of distortion that it
does is is it it puts us in a reactive
mode yes the Oil Pollution Act of 1990
was a reaction to a series of events but
it bears almost no mark of the
initiative of which I know my
professional companions are capable now
the other kind of context that I want to
put this in is the context of oil spills
in the larger context of marine
pollution even in marine pollution from
ships I'm the only one in this panel
that works almost exclusively on stuff
besides oil but it's worth reiterating
bill Kimes remarks that we have a legal
regime and though we've talked about
that legal regime in the context of oil
I will remind you now that it also
covers bulk chemicals carried in liquid
form packaged goods carried in
containers and other forms of boxes it
also covers solid waste and garbage
which you probably recognize as the the
plastics pollution in the United States
we also have controls over sewage from
ships and meanwhile while we
our meeting here both at the
international level and at the national
level we are working on new agreements
and new controls on air emissions both
from the cargos and from the propulsion
plants of the ships there are proposals
for a new International Convention on
solid cargoes such things as grain
taconite all the things that bunkers
carry and there is a lot of interest
right now in controlling the discharge
and the uptake of ballast water now I
find it's all kind of ironic and I can
say this in this crowd we've spent the
last umpteen years getting the ballast
water clean so we finally have it to the
point where we've now established
aquarium conditions and you go from one
continent to the other and you transfer
living organisms quite successfully so I
I feel like the agenda is changing
unless and we need to be aware of that
but it is valid to say that oil spills
trigger very intense reactions in people
and therefore they do tend to to rivet
the attention of the general public in a
way that a number of these other issues
don't so I think it's valid to say that
one of the oil spill issues is the way
it rivets the attention the director of
the Monterey Bay Aquarium used a phrase
that I just love and I repeat it
everywhere she says its charismatic
megafauna the reason people liked the
reason people get emotive over the
notion of oil spills is because they can
relate those wonderful seals all the
damages the megafauna okay and we also
heard some indication today of carrot
what I dubbed today charismatic
charismatic megafauna
I mean clearly when you were running the
America's Cup you had to find out where
the kelp beds were okay so i've now
included charismatic megafauna in the in
the jargon here but all of those demand
really very little attention to grab
your attention if you're going to focus
on the problem of oil spills if you're
going to focus on the problem of marine
pollution you have to incorporate the
nuance that Sylvia Earle was talking
about this morning you can't be
satisfied with a short attention span or
a short information span we can't use
two or three years of data to say it's
okay or it's down the tubes
in fact this year for example at the
ocean engineering department there's a
gentleman doing some work on ship wakes
because it turns out you can see ship
wakes four hours after the ship is gone
now this tells me that there is
something dynamic happening in the
surface layer of the ocean that we've
never acknowledged I don't know what it
is but it sure has something to do with
the surface dynamics of what you're
looking at when you're looking at an oil
spill so therefore I would like to also
say that I can no longer say I can no
longer tolerate the notion which seems
to be the abiding dogma that the open
oceans are not our principal concern if
you look at the way we have structured
our international regimes and our
national regimes and to a certain extent
our shipboard technologies we're
focusing on protecting the coasts to a
to an increasing degree the data that's
coming in on the middle of the ocean
tells us that is not necessarily a valid
conclusion what that tells me as an
engineer is that gives me the
opportunity to change from an end of the
pipe kind of a control system to a work
it from the beginning kind of a process
so that you don't have a high level of
pollution coming out of a ship at any
point during its operations Hank
mentioned earlier another important
point of context and we saw the slide
which shows that ships are in fact not
the dominant source of oil or the
dominant source of pollution in the
ocean this is an important statistic but
in fact it doesn't matter we are
responsible for ships it is our job to
do the best job we can cleaning up the
operations of ships and if those poor
people on land cannot get their act
together to do the same perhaps they
should look and see what we have
accomplished and learn from us and I
mean that quite literally we have
existing international agreements and I
understand that after the Rio summit
there's lots and lots and lots of things
ruminating about land-based sources of
ocean pollution we have a few models we
have a few precedents we have a few
incidents in examples of things to
implement that are worth taking a look
at because they've got a lot of hiccups
and a lot of problems in them but they
are moving in the right direction
specifically on the topic of regimes and
things like that I also want to be very
clear on one of my other biases which is
that once I found this
19:26 report and it has all the elements
of any report that you would write now I
have to state that I can no longer
tolerate the notion that we should be
cleaning up I I'm working now towards a
different performance standard at least
conceptually the the notion of less
worse doesn't make it for me anymore it
may be a 30 or 40 year achievement but
we really have to start thinking about a
different ship the notion of that oil
leaked and caused problems was on the
books seventy years ago it's not a new
surprise it shouldn't surprise us when
these events happen and we should be
able to engineer our way at least so
that we can respectively stand in front
of the congressional types and say we
have thought about this now leads me
right into my next statement which is
we've heard a lot of remarks quite
experienced voices speaking about the
problems with the Oil Pollution Act of
1990 and the 535 budding naval
architects in Congress you should be
alarmed and I'm telling you why you
should be alarmed because this shift in
power is real the shift in power away
from this profession and to the
legislature is something which can we
talk here they like it that way in the
context of oil spills I understand that
the anxiety attacks are coming on
largely in regards of how to cope with
the outrageous demands that have been
placed however they're not however all
discussions regarding ship service
pollution have been changed by this
discussion of oil pollution and oil
spills I have personally been involved
in discussions on air emissions from
propulsion plants garbage handling on
board ship and ballast water where I
have seen congressional staff people
talking about technical demonstration
programs and starting to design
technical demonstration programs and
they had neither the background nor did
they have the executive branch people
there who could help develop those plans
there is a comfort level right now with
intruding into the practice of marine
engineering and intruding into the
practice of naval our
texture which frankly gives me the
willies I consider myself an
environmental engineer though the title
seems to have gone to the civil
engineers this year and I don't
understand the acquiescence or the
overwhelming steamroller impression that
this has made on on the profession
finally therefore my my personal stand
is that it's up to us as marine
professionals to integrate the criteria
of marine pollution prevention into the
core disciplines of this profession
whether you're a engine designer a fuel
purchaser a cargo handler and I don't
know what every task that you should
undertake should have the opportunity to
at least articulate what the pollution
prevention needs are the possibilities
and whether you can execute them we
should not remain in this reactive
arrangement we should not be constantly
retrofitting our fleet exits go it's an
exorbitant way to deal with things it's
also the old-fashioned way most of the
other land-based industries have have
gone through at least one generation of
pollution control and we're getting the
old news we aren't getting the best
formulas for pollution prevention you
should certainly not wait until the next
legislature decides what the
technological fixes for your fleet or
for your state because in the case of
air emissions the ships who are being
targeted for action because the city was
not in compliance with its I'm doing
this because it's a kind of a bubble
concept you know the ozone concept there
is there is still it's really hard to
bite your tongue when you feel like
you've just been plowed over but
recently there was a very prominent
professional group which had a meeting
in Connecticut shall remain nameless but
the title of the session was this is a
quote bitter medicine the environment
get a life guys this is not going to go
away this is not a sometime thing this
is not something you can go hide in the
locker room and it'll resolve itself
stepping away from this issue will not
resolve any aspect of it in fact
labeling programs of prominent maritime
associations with titles like that will
only
only really give us the black eye that
everybody's been waiting to give us for
a long time so what I say to you as a
community of ocean engineers and the
community professionals in general is
get in line and work on the problem you
need to deputize yourself there's a
there's a quirk right now which a number
of us have come to grips with which is
there's no textbook on marine
environmental engineering we've engaged
a number of failed attempts to put one
together if you work in this field
publish your work please we need more
documents out there that aren't marked
navy secret to tell us what we're doing
here and in general the the plea I would
make to all of us as practicing marine
professionals is use your expertise you
may not consider yourself an
environmental professional but you know
more about the way a ship operates than
any of the environmental advocates who
are likely to come in contact with you
and if you don't volunteer that
information guess what I've learned in
the last couple years a lot of people
won't ask you but if you tell them they
might actually appreciate it so that's
my message thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Lisa you've done
done a great job of clearing the bases
here the the I'm gonna add one number to
your excellent presentation and I'll ask
the audience here Lloyd's casualty data
has just come out for 1991 so I want you
to think of what the number is of lives
lost just on those ships who have been
told losses whether the ships have been
casualty sunk whatever total losses how
many lives have been lost in 1991 I
think it's a hundred or 200 or 300 or
500 or 300 or 800 1200 more than 1,200
lives lost and and I think the the
general public has no no no idea with
the focus on things like oil spills that
some of these other problems still exist
before I open up question and answer
period to the audience I want to ask the
first question to Admiral chyme we have
mr. amber eCos talked about the
liability issues there is something
called the regulatory impact statement
is that the write the rate phrase the
Coast Guard is is a regulatory impact
analysis and our ia could you bring us
up to date on that
yes at the time that we were publishing
our notice of proposed rulemaking
several years ago the industry the
shipping industry in the oil industry
went to OMB and said that before this
can become final we in fact think
certain questions ought to be asked as
part of a regulatory impact analysis and
a little bit unusual and in fact they
gave oh and B a list of questions now
the Coast Guard has dutifully now
published that list of questions and we
have received a great many answers to
those we have sent the regulatory impact
analysis to the Department of
Transportation they have signed off on
it as we have and we have also sent it
to the Office of Management and Budget
and it's
they're about six weeks and we are
waiting for that to come out that will
be out
we hope sometime early this summer there
will be an opportunity for people to
make comment upon it many of the
comments that mr. Umberto eCos made are
addressed in some detail in that
there'll be 60 days for the public to
comment and then we would hope to move
on to finalizing the rules at that time
thank you
questions if I can see you yes the
reason and the reason for the sickness
and there were very interesting curves
right
the reason is that we have too many
ships the reason is that we have all
supplied the global market in the senses
through Japanese and Korean expansion
through stupid European subsidies and
we've continued the mystery in ages by
over agent at least to the tune of half
a year per year the average rate of
global tankers of vodka today are
fifteen years you're quite correct in
stating the taxes bill to apply to our
filter decisions if you are quite very
distinct in that if we look at the
tankers today there are two thirds of
the tactics that have to quit the
esterification size and many of them to
reputable company like yours are
hopefully properly operating but they're
quite a lot that are not correctly of
the mystery today is that we don't have
sufficient in the transportation sector
we don't get sufficient of the
value-added of the carpets in 1990 the
total global value of transportation was
roughly 1 billion dollars out of that
the ship owners got six and a half
percent twenty years back in your fear
detectors the price void was $2 the
transportation cost 477 today the oil is
priced at work some question goes
depends what the cost is still 70 now
I've not had we can talk about education
with the talk about been accruing we
could talk about maybe ships but we need
in the global system and increase in the
value added to the ship owners to the
shipping operators in order to do this
and this is today where we have the
mystery with all those old ships because
these old rust buckets pushing down them
up the market and if we don't solve that
problem we will not solve any of these
things that we've been talking about yet
we must
one way another by Kapinos
thank you I'd recommend against
torpedoes but the point is very
well-made sir it's it's a lot easier to
do all these extra things like training
and and more preparation when you're
making money when you can afford to buy
a brand new ship with all extra features
when you're losing money and and most
people have been losing money since 1973
it makes it much more difficult any any
comments Nick I think it's a mistake to
focus it on pure age of a ship like many
other pieces of equipment an older unit
can actually be much better than in
newer unit if it's properly maintained
from day one the fact that a ship is 20
years of age just means that it's 20
years of age
for example I'm sure there are many VL
cc's built in the 1970s that are
actually better ships better condition
than some built in the 1980s because of
the economy again shipyards went to high
tensile steel cutting down the
scantling's the thickness of the steel
with the same corrosion rate as the
thicker steel in older ships so again I
always have felt it's a mistake to
concentrate on age it's the operation of
the ship that makes a difference and
else
yes severed
okay the question has to do with the
impact of better navigation equipment
and do we have no accidents or do we
have technology assisted accidents I
like to comment the there's no question
that the biggest problem is not behind
the wheel and any in any mechanical
driven thing yeah you can have all the
equipment in the world but if you don't
have the right people - two men that
operate that equipment that ironically
is one of the problems that I think OPA
and perhaps in Europe if they follow the
same course is resulting it at a time
where we should be encouraging as a
country and as a world the finest young
men and women to follow a career at sea
we're sending them a message by putting
Joseph hazelwood's picture on the cover
of Time magazine by jailing the chief
mate on the ship that was in New York
Harbor that ran into a rock 35 Philippe
people of the Harbor bottle because he
did not see the rock and it turned out
he'd had a beer the night before he
spent two nights in jail a British
officer
the message we are sending to young
people and I have three sons is stay
away from that business I mean you have
nothing to gain except a possible prison
term again opa has introduced and the
states have followed very strongly the
criminal liability in terms of oil
pollution so I think that's one of the
problems we have to overcome how do we
keep those individuals have we spend
millions of dollars in training they'll
have long services with the companies
how do you keep them particularly coming
in to the United States and there are
cases where officers have refused the
sale on ships coming into the United
States for that reason and how do we
attract the new ones in it's it's a it's
maybe one of our bigger problems
comments I would like to add or that if
I heard you you weren't talking so much
about navigation equipment is that this
additionally that the deliberate skill
of navigating the vessel and I mean in
this country captain Gates has written a
wonderful text called god ship accidents
I think
called where where he talks about in
essence the loss of skill being the
cause of a number of accidents where
standard ops can be managed by a fairly
routine practiced event it's this skill
of saving a ship in a bad situation that
was lacking in many of these
circumstances not that it was an
impossible situation but that the calls
were wrong or the bank suction was too
extreme
Richard Cahill who is actually an
American but who was published in the UK
has written a couple of wonderful or
horrible depending on how you look at
these things what is called groundings
what the other ones called collisions
and their case studies and time and time
again it's a matter of pulling out the
old chart or not making sure that the
light you were looking at was the light
you were looking at and those sorts of
things are sort of legendary and from
what little I know as a spectator it's
it's initiatives like the bridge team
management which will if we're lucky
break through that impasse that you know
when you've got these horror stories
well hey we could all see it what's
going on the rocks but the old man was
at the wheel and we weren't gonna
overrule the old man you know then you
have to take a look at bridge team
management as perhaps a solution so I
think that that that what I'm worried
about is that the the the electronics
will break and nobody will know what to
do Hank let me also say that I think
bridge team management is something
that's extremely important it we can
mentioned that they were concentrating
on that I think we can learn a lesson
from the aviation industry there's going
to be a seminar in Oslo Norway on the
human element in avoiding ship accidents
taking place at the end of June I'm
going to have the privilege of being
there we're also bringing previous
administrator of the FAA who also
happened to be Vice Chief of Naval
Operations at one time having a view of
both the aircraft and and the sea
aspects of this to try to and to look at
those things
I think that's necessary we're going a
long way to - with navigational age
differential global positioning systems
that'll tell you within eight meters
where you are with ectis which is
electronic chart display and information
system which at any scale and with any
color scheme put a chart on a rate what
looks like a radar scope through
differential global positioning system
tell you within eight meters where your
ship is also there would be a collision
avoidance system all this will be I
think of tremendous to help to our
people we need the proper people in the
bridge we need properly trained people
and we also have to keep in mind things
that cause accidents also even if you
have those are pressures sometimes
placement ships it was mentioned about
the Aegean Sea that ran aground that
ship ran aground because it had been a
tanker for a long time and there was
tremendous pressure from the owner to
get that vessel in and the vessel did go
in under circumstances which you
shouldn't move so that again is part of
the equation part of safety management
from a corporation no matter how good
the equipment no matter how good well
the people are trained if in fact their
pressures to go in as there are many
times under adverse conditions we're
going to have accidents that comes under
quality management well by a ship owner
Thank You Lloyd
yes let me try and answer that one let's
talk about hard that the first of all
sure now the Aegean Sea is the most
recent one
she was a double bottom ship and what
happened is she ran aground you have
this huge double bottom this empty space
the inner hull was pierced you got
hydrocarbons in the empty space and you
got an explosion and it's only only to
be expected I mean the other there is
because there have been accidents where
basically if you have a high impact and
this is the the important part of it you
are going to pierce your inner shell and
that is inevitable and you'll pierce it
whether it's by grounding or whether as
in the case of the Merce navigator it's
by collision you have your structure in
this inner shell so the structure is in
your double bottom or in your double
hull when you have a high impact that
structure is going to pierce the inner
skin you're going to get hydrocarbons
into this empty space and a an explosion
then is nearly inevitable so really
where we're going for a design which
does save pollution there's no doubt
about it in the low impact accidents but
does not do so in the high impact
accidents in addition to that we're
creating ships that are built to be
higher up out of the water because you
have all this empty space so you you are
carrying your oil cargo much higher out
of the water when you you breach your
tank what's gonna happen is all this
cargo is going to come pouring out until
you have a hydrostatic balance so the
double hull is not a panacea and we
really have to accept this because
otherwise we're kidding ourselves
yeah anchor could I also disagree with
him because I think that's the reasoning
that led us to OPA 90 and the Congress
of the United States passing a
requirement for double hulls
in the case of the Aegean Sea this was a
vessel that was driven
12 to 15 knots into rocks it was not a
double hull tanker it was a combination
carrier that just happened to have a
double bottom you know it's it's like
saying I'm going to take care of myself
I'm going to eat well I'm going to
exercise I'm gonna live a long time and
then walk out into the southeast
expressway here without looking and
getting run over by a truck if you no
matter how you design a vessel you're in
no design is going to protect you at a
high-speed collision like that which was
pure human error you cannot extrapolate
that anytime you have an incident like
that you're going to have an explosion
we've had LNG ships running around the
world never lost a life in an LNG ship
one ran aground on a pinnacle in the
[Music]
Mediterranean ripped out almost the
entire bottom there was no explosion
there was no loss of cargo all most
chemical carriers most liquefied gas
carriers have double bottoms something
that is much more prone to leakage than
what you're talking about much more
volatile than a crude oil that you're
going to see certainly double hulls are
not going to protect you in every case
but they are in many cases going to
protect you to say that in fact the
Exxon Valdez would have been unstable
she was unstable when she was on the
pinnacle that's why we rushed the Coast
Guard and Exxon to salvage the vessel as
quickly as possible and take the 80% of
the cargo which didn't leak to make sure
we didn't have a spill much greater off
of there because she was structurally
unsound and she was unstable she was
only being held up by by Bligh reef if
in fact the vessel had had a double
bottom it would have come to rest like
that and only about 40 percent of the
oil that leaked would have leaked when
you talk about causing a double bottom
making a ship unstable because that
raises the center of gravity up to
meters or whatever that's assuming that
the naval architect is not ingenious
enough I would have not passed or
if I thought that it had been given by
Harvey Evans or someone like that a
problem to design a ship you've got to
meet certain stability requirements you
can make a ship stable and still raise
it up there's some constraints on it
they impact on the ability of the vessel
to go certain places but that's can
certainly be looked at
it will not as I said my words were it's
not the answer to a Maiden's prayer but
the American traders spill off of
Newport Beach California would have been
prevented by a simple double bottom and
I think that is something we need to
keep in mind it's not a panacea but it
will help in many many cases and I think
there's no basis to the argument that
you're creating an unsafe bomb and
certainly the Aegean Sea is no no valid
example in any case okay Lloyd question
number two
yeah
Senate pressure
[Music]
reason
yes
thank you thank you my right here
graduated on the
because disability
tough question once - who wants to start
on that let me start by saying my boss
the Secretary of Transportation federico
pena has been working extremely hard on
a maritime reform initiative to try to
build up the shipbuilding and the
shipping industry and the associated
jobs that go with it and the national
security aspects i'd also go with that
he was not successful in his first
effort but he's mounting up for another
charge i think the way to that is what
is going to have to be done we have to
provide some help to this industry other
nations all nations in one way or
another whether it's through direct
subsidy financing or something of that
nature do provide that i think that is
going to be necessary if we're going to
maintain a viable merchant marine
industry in this country and I think for
many reasons that that we we need to do
it
so we're behind my boss pushing working
on our part of it and hopefully and the
next go at this he will be successful
sometime later in the summer
yeah it's concerned to us we're working
on a a project to build two to four
American flight product tankers the
project is it doesn't many corporations
is grinding its way very thoroughly but
relatively slowly through the mill the
problems cost quite simply the American
rich marine officer has priced them out
himself out of herself out of the
international market and I'm to an
extent that you really can't compete
under the conditions Mobil I don't
notice for a fact that I have it on very
good authority Mobile is experimenting
this year with hiring a number of
graduates to sail on their non US flag
pleased I don't know under what terms
and conditions for example we have
Italian or British officers in addition
to our American officers and we are
looking at this as the result of mobiles
effort it would have to basically be at
the same conditions as the European
officers but that's not starvation wages
one of our concerns is that as we stay
in as an American controlled company
with an international fleet to the
extent the US wheat diminishes that
resource of bringing people through the
system I was a product of joining Texaco
as a third mate that system is
disappearing and so there has to be some
way of continuing our accessibility into
it was an extremely valuable asset and
that's the young young people coming out
of the academies today yeah I'd like to
try to answer it very personal
perspective since I don't hire anybody
and that's probably the most that you
guys can speak from I'm now about let's
see eighteen years or so out of school I
miss not having any kind I miss having
some company there's hardly anybody that
I feel a particular kinship to my Marg
rad friends normally don't have a whole
lot of education on environmental issues
and though the curriculums have changed
and people understand operationally what
the the directives are the looking ahead
skills are really not being cultivated
in a way that I would love to have it
done my nan Margret friends who are
coming out of naval architecture
curriculums and marine engineering
curriculums and elsewhere are finding it
very difficult to find commercial work
to do so that in the year classes behind
me overwhelmingly people took jobs doing
Navy work and they've learned how to
design ships for the Navy which is a
fine skill but not the same skill as
designing and operating ships for
commercial use or regulating ships that
are in commercial use I don't have any
particular solution but I I'm at the
point now where I'm more or less the
same age that the guys who worked with
me when I was 22 and 23 were and I
learned a lot from working with them and
I really feel the lack of people to sort
of cultivate this particular skill set I
have any solution to sympathy birth
question over here
certain good I'd like to hear from the
from the pan what's the first thing I'll
point out is that we are rather unique
as a major industrialized nation in the
way you have only one offshore terminal
and and last counter certainly more than
110 I don't know how many there are now
but we do not have many offshore
terminals and that that certainly would
move those ships away from our shores is
as one one approach oh I'm sorry
the questioner is really the role of
ports the the potential impact of port
design on this whole problem and and one
topic that that's being discussed or I
don't know if it's still being discussed
or not but Chelsea Creek in Boston area
we ships go up this if they don't hit
the bridge on the way they go up the the
Chelsea Creek and and certainly people
have been talking about moving that
entire system offshore and doing it
through hoses and pipes and I don't know
to what extent OPA addresses those kinds
of things
no-oh-oh PA 90 does have restrictions on
navigation and safeguards to be
considered such as numbers of people on
the bridge talking escorts tanker
exclusion zones things of that nature
that are going to be addressed but I
think your your point of whether we
should go with offshore terminals or not
is is is very good when we do have one
offshore terminal loop down in Louisiana
there's been consideration for a second
offshore terminal off of Texas the
problem is right now that it is not
economically viable to do that and I
think that's the thing obviously if the
deep draft tankers could be kept
offshore
I think loop last year I just signed the
report to the Congress that we have to
send up once a year I think they spilled
a hundred and forty seven gallons of oil
and most of that probably vaporized
before it hit the water so obviously
that is a way to go but the economics of
it just don't seem to be there also you
have to have an infrastructure you have
to see where the pipelines are the
distribution systems etcetera
there are some offshore terminals off of
California but they probably contribute
to as many accidents as they prevent
although some new initiatives have been
taken with the Coast Guard in the state
of California certainly that is an area
we should look at more for future
terminals and certainly environmentally
that is a tremendous way to reduce the
types and dangers that that we've seen
recently one comment on ports ports are
assumed to provide services to ships
under several of the legal regimes in
facilities called port reception
facilities I think it's fair to say that
that's been one of the great catch-22 is
of the legal regime and so it would be
interesting to get your perspective as a
planner on a port plan that that dealt
with that and was able to deal with the
costs and the constructions and the
local planning and everything else
because we keep returning to this now
now with the the flag state
implementation committee and I am oh I'm
really looking forward to seeing what
people are will finally confront on the
notion of port reception facilities and
how do you provide them and what are the
minimum standards of performance and and
so there there is an assumption that
ports as a participant in both
operational and accidental pollution
prevention but it's always been more or
less attributed without being
articulated in a way that you can find
the professional skill set to really
tell somebody if you're designing a new
port this is the way to go I'm just
going to say can you brought back a
memory Hank I was 1964 I was second mate
on a tanker they hit the Chelsea bridge
it's it's still there but it's it it's
been beating around a while didn't kill
it I think Alex
[Music]
happens the Torrey Canyon
Valdez domain all our red I have the
privileged information economies have
told chaotic states confusion between
state authorities and federal
authorities no one really dare do one
thing without having to change that I
mean I think that I am the state
good question that's a good let me say
that all of the oil did spill from the
Exxon Valdez spilled in 11 hours and
Exxon made the statement and the
scientific Support Coordinator who from
NOAA who provided scientific advice to
the federal on-scene coordinator agreed
that had Exxon had right next to blye
reef at the instant the vessel grounded
the maximum amount of equipment that it
had at any stage of the cleanup it would
have made about a 10 or 20 percent
difference in the amount of oil that
came out the the issue is to keep the
oil in the ship in the first place now
the question of the organization
surrounding the Exxon Valdez if any of
you saw the HBO movie reversed that
about a hundred and eighty degrees and
although my good friend Franco Rossi
came out very well in that I was glad to
see it didn't talk about the reality
what you had there was a a port that
that had a spill Alyeska and Exxon had
representatives the Coast Guard had a
commander on scene in the state of
Alaska had a gentleman and see the ADEC
representative and then this happened
and what happened was that everybody
descended on scene the Secretary of
Transportation the Commandant of the
Coast Guard the district commander the
president of Exxon itself the president
of Exxon tankers the governor of Alaska
and every news anchor person that could
buy a ticket all descending on scene
when I was up there one of the biggest
jobs I had was taken care of visiting
fireman
we had a protocol office and and we we
took care of these people and still let
the cleanup go on these people have a
right to know they have a reason to know
but what we did not have in place at
that time we had a great organization
for a typical spill of which there's
8,000 a year in our waters but not a
spill of national significance
Suns and when rewriting the National
contingency plan we have put together an
organization that we are going to
utilize at least the Coast Guard is the
EPA is still looking at it but a very
specific organization that will take the
lessons learn from the Exxon Valdez to
keep this kind of confusion or perceived
confusion down so that the people that
need to know will know the elected
officials the media and at the same time
the cleanup will go on at a well
organized way resources will be brought
to bear very very quickly so hopefully
we have an organization that will solve
that problem I think it's a very good
organization we put together I used I
was the federal on-scene coordinator
when the American traitor
went aground and having been up in
Alaska we utilize those lessons learned
we'd haven't written down but Jim card
whose name was mentioned and I were
there and we were able to skim about 35%
of the oil from that incident that's the
most anyone has ever skimmed and we kept
the media going and kept this off the
front page after about two days so I
think we've we've learned some lessons
but that is a very key thing and that
again is something that OPA 90 has has
mandated not just for a federal national
plan but for local plans and for the
plans as dick talked about for ships and
and terminals follow-up for our last
question
[Music]
well certainly Lord Caithness and the
British government are still doing their
investigation of that incident
concerning dispersants I don't think
we've learned anything since the Torrey
Canyon about dispersants we have this
mindset that I discussed in my comments
there are places to use detergents in
places not to use dispersants there's
the proper quantity to use there needs
to be pre-planning approval as EPA does
of the types of dispersants and then the
plans that I talked about have to say at
certain times of the year under certain
conditions you go through a matrix yes
you may
yes you may not or you may under certain
other circumstances use a dispersant
that's what we need to to know the
farmers I think as a result of the
prayer were impacted by fumes from the
oil that was was was coming out there
we're interested to see what really
happened there of course they had a
tremendous high energy sea that had a
great effect we didn't have that in
Alaska we had a lot of low energy
beaches where a natural dispersion
didn't didn't take place how effective
dispersants were I don't know we're
gonna have to wait to see what the
British government says any final
comments from the panel let me let me
thank the audience for their Oh Phillip
will give you the last question if it's
a short one
what is everyone picking on me I got
blamed here for my good friend for a low
freight rates in the tanker industry the
Johnstown Flood and the fact that
Michael Jackson can't hit his jump shot
probably Larry Bird's back go ahead my
friend
[Music]
and there is something
I mean very low surface tension if we
surface tension of the on this stress
apparently they are looking into
something they have found something
when the charity do that yourself and it
gives it back to you pretty good back to
whatever it is and this was so hot
[Music]
the ice cream dispenser
well you get the the final you'll have
the final jello be looked at OPA 90 does
require a coordinated R&D regime in this
country the Coast Guard heads that up
along with all the federal agencies we
are taking all the ideas that we can
find things such of a nature to solidify
the cargo to change its physical
characteristics those are the things
that are being looked at we also through
the International Maritime Organization
or response at an R&D seminar in this
country to coordinate internationally
there's precious few dollars available
unfortunately for R&D in this area we've
got to make sure we we don't duplicate
finally Hank let me since I do have the
last word someone said we don't have a
publication on environmental
considerations in this country that we
need coming from ships as president of
society of naval architects that is an
initiative I'm undertaking so if there
are any of you out there who would like
to be the editor of this publication or
a contributor hopefully at our national
meeting not this September but October
or the following year in New Orleans we
hope to dedicate that technical session
to these issues it's it's multifaceted
we've heard all parts of it but we do
think that as an industry we need to pay
the same attention to this as we do to
structural design machinery design and
things resistance and hull form that the
society has traditionally paid attention
to thank you for ending on a positive
note I want to thank the audience for
your attention and participation and our
panelists have been outstanding thank
you very much
[Applause]
meeting adjourned